additional security forces are deployed
across australia's biggest city sydney
to enforce a covet 19 lockdown in its
eighth week
the city registered its largest one-day
increase of infections on monday
officials are telling people to prepare
for the surge to continue
and in new zealand the announcement that
an area where the country's first
coveted 19 case in six months was found
faces a snap lockdown for a week we have
made decisions on the basis that it is
better to start high and go down levels
rather than start too low
not contain the virus and see it move
quickly
we've seen the dire consequences of
taking too long to act in other
countries not least our neighbours
thailand just had its record number of
single day deaths on tuesday with 239
this says the number of infections in
the third and strongest wave inches
toward one million that's just since
april and is fueled by the delta variant
the nation is struggling to increase its
vaccination rates that now stand at just
more than seven percent for those fully
vaccinated 25 percent of the 70 million
population have received their first
dose vaccine supply has been an issue
from the start the thai government
playing catch-up just ordered 10 million
doses of pfizer and 12 million of
cenovak
japan is extending its state of
emergency in tokyo in seven more regions
until september 12th there will also be
widening restrictions in seven more
prefectures the nation has seen a rise
in new infections setting a new daily
record last week but lockdown fatigue is
prompting some to feel skeptical about
the extended measures
honestly there's no impact if the state
of emergency is similar to the previous
ones everyone is numb to it and it's
more like not again
so its content needs to be different
from before or it will have little
effect
in indonesia one of the worst hit
nations in asia rights group animal
defender is stepping in to help pet
owners who have kovit 19. they take care
of pets left alone when their owners are
in hospital or are put into isolation
we are just a forms of assistance
according to the needs of the pet owners
either to evacuate and take care of it
completely or we take care of it
temporarily like lettuce we help to feed
the animals clean the cage or bathe the
dogs
he says the biggest challenge of the
work is when they get notified that a
pet's owner has died scott heidler al
jazeera bangkok